[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez avec moi le matin du 11
juin 2007 vous auriez probablement vécu
l'expérience curé transformer le cours
de votre vie j'étais seul dans mon
appartement je préparais mon petit
déjeuner quand soudainement j'ai
ressenti un mal de tête très fort si
fort que je suis tombé au sol
peut-être ma tête a violemment heurté le
sol je m'en souviens pas une chose est
sûre c'est que ça aurait pu être la fin
pour moi
n'avez vous jamais vécu une expérience
qui dramatique qui vous amène à
réfléchir sur ce que vous auriez pu
mieux faire
eh bien c'est ce qui s'est passé pour
moi g j'étais stressé à l'époque je
travaillais dur je ne mangeais pas ces
jeux ne buvait pas assez je ne faisais
pas assez de sport
mes relations sociales professionnelles
et est d'une médiocrité indicible et ça
c'était ma perspective d'employés
aujourd'hui je conseille des entreprises
sur des problématiques de capital humain
et je peux maintenant me rendre compte
en étant de l'autre côté que ma manager
n'était pas le problème comme je pouvais
le croire penser à l'époque mais c'était
plutôt la manière dont elle était gérée
aujourd'hui ne demandait pas un chef
d'entreprise sa stratégie sa vision il
va probablement vous répondre avec
pertinence
demandez lui plutôt comment est-ce que
sa vision sa stratégie et exécutés et
vous vous rendrez compte que frustration
souffrance concerne bon nombre
d'entreprises
mon expérience m'a amené à constater
quelques mots et ce ne sont que
quelques-uns dans la pratique de
certaines entreprises
l'avarice des salaires qui stagnent
pendant des années des gens qui restent
au même poste pendant des années alors
que les entreprises ont les moyens
l'avidité cette quête du pouvoir et
freiner ou finalement des collaborateurs
sont capables de causer le pire à leurs
propres collègues voire à leur famille
lego quand il n'est pas bien maîtrisés
légaux que nous doute détruire nous
mêmes peut également détruire les autres
autour de nous
le pire à notre époque c'est que
l'empathie est perçu comme une faiblesse
la cupidité
cette quête cette quête du gain
financier du gain matériel qui nous fait
perdre tout sens de l'humanité
la méfiance dans pas mal d'entreprises
il y à des esprits critiques d esprit
fin mai ses esprits au lieu d'être
constitue au lieu d'être considérés
comme des solutions sont plutôt
considérés comme des menaces notamment
dans les entreprises où il ya la culture
du chef on le contredit pas le chef
n'avez vous jamais été victime ou
acteurs d'un de ses mots en fait si on
regarde bien
ces mots ne relève pas de des carences
du leadership mais relève de la
responsabilité de tout un chacun ses
mots finalement quand on regarde bien
émane de notre propre soit
les emon de notre propre soit et
constitue finalement des limites qu'on
se doit de dépasser pour atteindre des
meilleurs niveaux de performance
probablement jamais égalée auparavant
à ce sujet il ya une étude très
intéressante de l'université de harvard
qui a été menée sur plus de 75 ans à
travers des catégories
socioprofessionnelles tout diverses les
unes des autres et qui a démontré que ni
l'argent ni la célébrité ni le pouvoir
de constituer le bonheur en revanche les
relations sociales les relations
humaines de qualité mène à une vie plus
longue plus fructueuse alors pour
pouvoir cultiver ses relations humaines
de qualité dans le cadre d'une
entreprise il ya des tas d'outils
j'ai noté quelques recommandations à
partager avec vous le sens redéfinir le
sens dans lequel on travaille dans les
entreprises en fait donner du sens à
chacune des actions derrière notre
travail quel que soit le travail mais il
donnait du sens savoir qu' on travaille
pour servir une cause bien plus grande
que sa propre personne que ses propres
intérêts ensuite il ya la communication
de ce sens ne pas atteindre ne pas
attendre le début d'année où la fin
d'année mais communiquer régulièrement
avec le personnel il y à l'innovation
autour du traitement des employés
aujourd'hui des start up des pme des
grandes entreprises
on fait le choix et je veux dire même
ont eu le courage de mettre en avant les
employés il est en 2d les clients parce
que le bien-être des premiers
conditionne la satisfaction des seconds
on le voit aujourd'hui c'est tout récent
certes les managers du bien-être les
managers du bonheur alors ça a suscité
la risée
mais au final on doit saluer le courage
de ces chefs d'entreprise qui ont décidé
de mettre l'homme devant l'humain devant
la démystification du leader créer du
lien entre les leaders le leadership et
le personnel et on peut créer du lien
avec des éléments très simple avec des
outils d'une simplicité in win tout
simplement un déjeuner entre le dg et le
reste du personnel ça change
complètement la perspective du personnel
des activités de cohésion des équipes
chose toute simple réduire le gap entre
les leaders et le personnel pourquoi ne
pas démocratisé la présence de membres
du personnel au sein des conseils
d'administration
alors je voudrais partager maintenant
quelques éléments d'un tout harmonieux
ce tout harmonieux quantité constitué
d'abord de l'intégrité cultiver la
relation entre la parole et l'action
si on dit qu'on va augmenter les
salaires qu'on va attribuer des bonus
qu'on va gratifier promouvoir bien qu'on
s'y tiennent ça ne fera que qu accroître
la confiance au sein des équipes entre
les équipes au sein de l'entreprise la
manière
considérer l'autre pour ce qu'il est
indépendamment de son statut
hiérarchique sa situation sociale de ses
origines de sa communauté et j'en passe
juste le considérait pour ce qu'il est
l'unité parce que l'union fait la force
partager la connaissance l'expérience au
sein des équipes entre les équipes dans
l'entreprise humilité
savoir écouter l'autre je me souviens
d'un fils j'étais tout jeune
collaborateur dans la banque lui était
directeur na fils avait toujours un
moment pour m'écouter pour me conseiller
pour me guider
en janvier 2010 il nous a quittés d'un
cancer aujourd'hui tout ce que je
retiens ce sont ces actions ces petites
actions qu'il a eu à mon égard qui font
qu'aujourd'hui ça m'inspire pour faire
la même chose si ce n'est mieux non
le courage de dire non à tout ce qui va
à l'encontre d'un environnement de
travail sain l environnement de travail
agréable où on respecte l'autre
authenticité authenticité finalement
l'authenticité c'est l'intégrité
vis-à-vis de soi c'est s'accepter
soi-même tel qu'on est
et se faire accepter par les autres tel
que l'on est
vous savez les qualités humaines qui
sont en chacun de nous nous nous devons
de les explorer nous nous devons de les
multiplier de faire en sorte que on soit
encore plus humain dans les entreprises
si ce n'est pas être plus humain au
moins rester humain je voudrais citer je
voudrais citer ce grand poète soufi
jalaluddin omis qui nous invite à la
question suivante pourquoi restez-vous
en prison quand la porte est grande
ouverte
merci
[Applaudissements]